vive la république vive la france la
droite est complètement explosé parce qu
emmanuel macron très intelligemment fait
venir la droite juppéiste lui offre les
clés une partie des clés du pouvoir
nommé douar philippe à matignon nomme
bruno le maire à bercy nomme gérald
darmanin au budget darmanin jeune espoir
edouard philippe beaucoup moins connu
mais quand même maire du havre est
proche de très proche de juppé donc
incarnant la ligne juppé est donc toute
une partie de l'électorat de droite va
aller je verrai manuel macro il se
trouve que je suis moi-même un homme de
droite ce qui ne vous surprendra pas je
le sais
les élus les républicains sont quand
même tous ce n'est pas ce qu'on leur
avait promis la victoire et puis
finissent en troisième position
donc comment se les procès pour trahison
au sein du parti il y à il ya plusieurs
écoles il ya ceux qui veulent travailler
avec le nouveau chef de l'état il ya
ceux qui ne veulent pas donc c'est la
suite de la guerre copé fillon mais
d'une autre manière
[Musique]
on
tout juste élu en mai 2010 est emmanuel
macron se pose en président rassembleur
il convainc de plus en plus les élus et
l'électorat de droite et lors des
législatives qui suivent la droite
largement battue par la république en
marche
on pouvait imaginer que la législative
soit un épisode de revanche pour
lecteurs à droite qui s'était fait voler
sa présidentielle
mais ce rééquilibrage ne sera pas
possible à cause de l'intelligence
politique de maquereau en ce moment là
qui a créé le désordre et la division à
l'intérieur du camp du camp de
l'adversaire le ralliement des juppéiste
à emmanuel macron pose aussi la question
des lignes à droite et des sensibilités
et donc une vraie question de fond
derrière mais qui a du mal à être
traités en tant que tel au sein des
républicains parce qu'ils sont dans un
climat de deux défaites et donc certains
poissons pour les sanctionner en les
virant carrément du parti d'autres sont
pour finalement comprendre ce départ et
que ça ne crée pas de fracture
supplémentaires et donc on arrive à un
nouveau psychodrame pendant des semaines
il ya les républicains qui s'interrogent
faut-il les exclure ou pas on ne peut
pas être le premier ministre de la
france chef de la majorité et est membre
du parti du principal parti d'opposition
c'est juste pas possible ça n'a pas de
sens pour rebondir il faut donc se
trouver un nouveau chef et c'est laurent
wauquiez qui va se présenter en tant
qu'art chiffres avori face à florence
portelli et mal de calan le 10 décembre
il est élu avec plus de 74% des voix dès
le premier tour
oui ce soir nous pouvons dire la droite
est de retour certes voquer et
confortablement élu certes il verrouille
le parti pour être tranquille mais le
problème c'est qu'il n'arrive pas à
convaincre les électeurs que sa ligne
est la bonne mais le problème c'est que
là on voit l'écart le plus grandissant
possible entre les militants se replie
sur un noyau dur et les sympathisants
électorat qui eux représente l'ensemble
des droites et eux sont plus proches
finalement d'un emmanuel macron très
vite il ya une forme d'isolement à
l'intérieur des républicains et donc ça
va être une de ses grandes faiblesses
en plus il va se brouiller avec nicolas
sarkozy donc il ya il augmente les
difficultés pour résoudre le problème
principal qui l'a avant même de
conquérir le pouvoir qui est de créer
qui est de rassembler dans son intérêt
de son corps et le problème c'est que
leur envient qui très vite va avoir un
procès en un sincérité qui va lui lui
tomber dessus parce que il était d'abord
auprès de jacques barrot en haute-loire
centriste et qu'il a évolué vers une
droite un peu plus dur
critiquant le cancer de l'assistanat et
ensuite ne se prononceront pas
clairement pour emmanuel macron dans
l'entre-deux tours de la présidentielle
face à marine le pen et 2018 aurait pu
être une pause dans l'histoire de la
droite
sauf que il faut se souvenir que des fin
il ya d'autres ténors qui sont parti des
républicains je pensais que xavier
bertrand
donc ça laisse des traces surtout que
les juppéiste vont attirer d'autres élus
les républicains et donc on sent en 2018
qu'alain juppé ou jean pierre raffarin
qui sont des figures quand même deux du
parti prennent leur distance tous
condamnant la politique mise en place
par laurent wauquiez au sein des
républicains donc même s'il n'ya pas
d'élection en tant que tel en 2018 et
que donc on a pas de mesure pour voir
les divisions
on les sent il ya des départs il y à des
déclarations et puis finalement tous ces
élus n'arrivent même plus à se parler
autour d'une table ils n'ont plus envie
d'avancer ensemble et c'est dans cette
ambiance houleuse électrique que se
profilent les élections européennes de
2019 très rapidement laurent wauquiez
avait l'idée de maître françois-xavier
bellamy comme candidat des européennes
parce que pour lui c'était la droite des
convictions donc il affirmait ce qu'il
était et puis c'était une nouvelle tête
qui était peu connu du grand public donc
lavées l'idée de re nouvelle sauf que
beaucoup au sein des républicains
contestent ce choix et cette ligne
politique et donc demande à laurent
wauquiez de créer une sorte de trio
s'est notamment l'idée de gérard larcher
et donc à partir de ce moment là se met
en place presque une candidature à trois
têtes et donc il ya françois xavier
bellamy il ya aussi agnès evren qui est
proche de françois baroin et valérie
pécresse qu'une autre ligne et puis
arnaud danjean qui lui était dans
l'équipe
alain juppé et le trio fonctionne assez
bien et les élus sont agréablement
surpris en reconnaissant pour le coup à
laurent wauquiez de d'avoir entendu
cette fois ci sur une ligne qui aurait
pu séduire l'électorat dit fillon
s'était salalah la stratégie c'est
essayer de récupérer les 20 % d'un
électorat qui malgré les tombereaux
d'insultés qui sont tombées sur françois
fillon malgré les les problèmes les
chausse pied de chausse trappes de la
campagne a réussi à faire 20% ont donc
on se dit c'est être là va voter à
droite tout le temps maintenant il 6 il
a voté pour demain en 2017 pour un mec
pour françois fillon il va continuer la
campagne des républicains se passe
plutôt bien sur le terrain et pour la
première fois depuis 2012 on revoit une
effervescence dans les salles on revoit
des militants qui sont heureux d'être là
et on revoit certains militants qu'on ne
voyait plus notamment des plus jeunes ou
quelques classes populaires c'est pas en
masse mais on en voit certains donc les
élus les militants se disent tiens il se
passe quelque chose est-ce que c'est pas
bon signe
et ils ont tous envie d'y croire ils se
disent y'a
un effet bel ami finalement il n'arrive
pas à trouver le chemin pour être une
alternative l'électorat catholique de
droite
ancré dans les yvelines dans les
hauts-de-seine mais même dans dans
l'ouest parisien va passer en masse pour
voter lrm et ne pas voter sur la ligne
qui a été adopté par laurent wauquiez
est porté par françois-xavier mais l'ami
européenne à la fin de la campagne on
sent que le duel s'installe entre en
marche et leur assemblage le
rassemblement national et donc on voit
que les républicains en moins d espace
mais à ce moment là on s'attend à un
résultat qui serait moyen autour de 11
12 13 %
or vers 19h30 19h45 quand on commence à
avoir les premiers résultats on
s'aperçoit que le score des républicains
va être bien plus bas que prévu et ça
personne n'avait imaginé que les
républicains passerait sous la barre
décembre la barre symbolique des 10% qui
est quand même une barre qui créé un
électrochoc à droite la ligne macron
peut finir par s'identifier à une partie
de la droite donc danger pour
les républicains c'est d'être
définitivement dépossédé d'une partie de
leurs électeurs les années qui viennent
vont être décisives et s'il reste sur
une ligne très très conservatrice sans
être ni européen ou très peu ni libéraux
ou pas suffisamment ils vont ils vont
s'aliéner d'effectivement une grande
partie de l'électorat classique de la
droite
la société a changé en 12 ans et les
républicains n'ont pas forcément avancer
de
nouvelle réponse autant nicolas sarkozy
avait fait un gros travail de réflexion
et sur le fond avant l'élection 2007
autant on a un peu l'impression que
pendant 12 ans les républicains vont
vivre sur ses solutions apportées en
2007 mais qui parfois paraissent
aujourd'hui un peu datés c'est à dire
qu'il manque un gros travail sur les
idées et finalement le débat une à
tourner qu'autour des personnalités et
des individualités et ça les militants
n'en peuvent plus et les électeurs non
plus en dix ans la guerre des chefs
ça va on a connu si vous n'avez rien
d'autre à nous proposer on ira voir
ailleurs et c'est ce qui se passe les
électeurs ne croient plus dans les
parties plus dans les slogans et donc
les mobilisations qui pouvait se faire
autour d'un homme et d'un slogan sont de
plus en plus difficile et la droite qui
est là depuis très longtemps comme le
parti socialiste
au fond elle a fini par le payer
[Musique]